>> RHODE: Hangout during Oktoberfest by some
amazing, amazing coincidence of timing.
Every single sales organization across all
of Google has to have an offsite meeting in
the Munich office this week.
Who knows?
I don't know.
The stars must have come in into an alignment.
But anyways, those of us who arenít in sales
are here to talk to you about anything and
everything having to do with Android Development.
So I'm Sparky coming to you from Munich, Germany.
And I'm also joined by Nick and Rich in London,
UK.
So, hello everyone.
Welcome.
It's a Wednesday afternoon.
Let's talk Android.
>> HYNDMAN: Well, it's Nick, Rich and Matt
is at--Matt?
What happened to Matt?
[INDISTINCT] Android, damn it as always.
Hi.
How are you doing?
>> BUTCHER: And he seems to also be at Al's
house at the same time.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
He'sÖ
>> SUTTON: He gets everywhere.
>> HYNDMAN: And sat between us two.
>> BUTCHER: And Al's--and Matt's been out
to another shift for the week so he's guesting
in Mountainview so he's fast asleep right
now unless he joins the Hangout.
>> HYNDMAN: Thatís a poor excuse but anyway.
He could be working out.
We should pity him.
So as usual, today we will be talking about
anything that previously has not been announced.
Thatís something has recently being announced
that we can talk about.
What time did that go live that blogpost?
>> BUTCHER: Midday.
It's been out today.
>> HYNDMAN: Midday today, couple of hours
ago.
We announced the Google Play Store has now
had 25 billion installs.
>> BUTCHER: Widget and thunder.
>> HYNDMAN: But the Google Play has had 25
billion--we--I'll doing it again so we could
synchronize--installs.
And as part of that, we're having a promotion.
We have 25 apps, games, books, movies if those
books were launched in your country.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
Keep an eye on the Google Play Store and later
today we'll be announcing which apps is going
to be on sale and books and other content
as well so keep an eye out for some celebrations
and some bargains.
>> HYNDMAN: It should be like [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: Oh, my goodness.
I can feel the numbers melting of my credit
card already.
When we had our--when we had our 10 billion
promotion last fall--when was it, November?
I bought I think 56 apps during that promotion.
Now, what I'm going to do this time?
>> HYNDMAN: I spent $5.60 on apps.
Jeez.
Do you remember about your weather?
I was in an airport with someone using FlightTrack.
And they go, "Wow.
That app's amazing, I should get that."
Then they checked the Play Store.
It turns out that they bought it during the
10/10/10 promotion.
They didn't quite remember that they bought
it so they were quite happy to see it as a
purchased application.
Yeah.
I'll also be buying.
I think every single application during the
next promotion which is going to be a bargain
this weekÖ
>> RHODE: I have FlightTrack but honestly
I've gotten a lot more used out of Flight
Control.
>> SUTTON: The game?
>> RHODE: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: I think this is more about your
travel habits and then it's [INDISTINCT] Sparky.
>> HYNDMAN: I must apologize for the quality
of our video today.
We seem quite pixilated.
We'll try to sit really still.
And hope you don't...
>> RHODE: Dumdidum didum.
I'll be taking an hour okay?
>> HYNDMAN: Sparky's got control.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT] before we hit the
[INDISTINCT] I jumped [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: There you go.
First Nick, now me.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
But also we hit the [INDISTINCT] jump out
of my seat and smashed my Nexus 7 so it's
no longer responding.
>> HYNDMAN: Thatís glass sticking out.
I can make extreme close-up.
>> RHODE: Nick, we know it's just the way
you want to get some more credit for the Play
Store Sale.
>> HYNDMAN: Thatís every single app like
four times over at least.
Excellent.
>> BUTCHER: So Al, I've been seeing some posts
of you on Google+ about AOSP.tv.
What is that?
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
It's a little project that started at the
[INDISTINCT] on about a week and a half ago.
I'm taking the Android Open Source Project
which is basically the way that you guys make
Android available to the rest of the world
and making it more suitable for a TV.
And one of the first steps was being able
to use another device to control it.
So what I'm showing is a Galaxy Nexus and
the Nexus S, both being the main gaming machine,
both running Quake and sitting back with an
Xperia Play, and using that as the controller.
>> BUTCHER: Nice.
So you're connecting that for standard Android
like phone device using--and then using HDMI
out to play this content into the TV?
>> SUTTON: Yup, thatís exactly it.
Thatís all I'm doing on that side.
AndÖ
>> HYNDMAN: Well, on a second Android device
to control it?
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
So, you can set your phone in front of your
TV and connect to app and then it uses Bluetooth
to connect to anybody else if anyone wants
to sit around and play games.
>> BUTCHER: : Nice.
Even an old--and old Android device with HDMI
out sitting in a drawer somewhere, why not
in your TV and connect to the TV?
?
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Well, my Nexus S is probably going to live
for awhile now.
>> HYNDMAN: To the Nexus S, thanks to you
now.
>> BUTCHER: Al, how are you doing that?
It's a Nexus S [INDISTINCT] HDMI did?
>> SUTTON: There was a--I thought there was
a connector you could get for it.
I've got one for the Galaxy Nexus which is
HDMI [INDISTINCT] connector but I thought
that goes back which is compatible with the
Nexus S.
>> HYNDMAN: I don't think the Nexus S [INDISTINCT]
becauseÖ
>> RHODE: Not that I recall.
>> HYNDMAN: Ödocumentations.
We have these [INDISTINCT] together [INDISTINCT]
problems with them [INDISTINCT] things sold
into the back of it.
>> SUTTON: Looks like I'm going to have to
go device hunting in my box for another one
who's got the HDMI out.
Maybe my Optimus 2X will find--see the light
of day again.
>> RHODE: I think I'm--I think we got a couple
of tablets that might be a good candidate
for hooking up to a TV.
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT] to you, Rick and
Paul [INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: Nick.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
[INDISTINCT]
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
Thatís right.
What I'm doing is the Nexus S and the Galaxy
Nexus are both supported in the Android Open
Source Project but so as the WiFi zone and
might try to release the boot later unlocker
that we're keeping at the UK WiFi 1.
So I should be able to get it running on that.
And given the amount of change is that I've
made a quite minimal.
I could probably also draft it onto [INDISTINCT]
mod and opens up a whole world of extra devices
that it could run up.
>> BUTCHER: Nice.
>> HYNDMAN: Excellent.
Excellent, excellent work.
>> SUTTON: Thank you.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT] myself.
>> BUTCHER: So, who else has joined us who
I have just muted?
>> RHODE: Paul Hanson has joined us in Hangout.
I seem to recall, did--Paul, did you warn
us ahead of time that you're going to ask
us a standard question?
>> HANSON: Yes.
[INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Radical.
>> RHODE: We're stunned.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT] No.
Go ahead.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: Did he say yes?
I heard him say yes.
>> RHODE: I heard that too.
>> HYNDMAN: Question, Paul?
>> RHODE: Let me see if I can try at the moderator.
I think it's this one.
Well, this is--this is sort of coming from
Pablo in Central England but I thought this
was Paul's question.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We read smart cards fits with fixed power
on self [INDISTINCT] time.
Most need a second to complete.
Android default NFC, ISO depth time out of
0.3 seconds is too short.
Gingerbread, we can overwrite this to two
seconds, works well.
ICS and Jelly Bean does not work, any ideas?
If I had any expertise in NFC, I would share
it with you.
>> HYNDMAN: How do we need to get Trevor on
the line?
You need to ask this in the Mountainview office
hours in eight hours time.
Because Trevor did a whole lot of work with
NFC and wrote a superb app for scanning mobile
or congress badges.
>> RHODE: Interestingly, I went on a vacation
recently and they gave us NFC room key.
I did not do as Trevor did.
I didn't reverse engineer it or turned my
phone into a virtual room key or anything
but it was--it was pretty cool to be able
to read the data out of my room key using
that phone.
Give me a really warm fuzzy feeling about
the security of this hotel room.
>> HANSON: Can you hear me?
Can you hear me too on thisÖ
>> HYNDMAN: Yup, we can hear you.
>> [INDISTINCT] now.
>> HANSON: I work--my sound [INDISTINCT] through
okay?
>> HYNDMAN: Yup, great.
>> HANSON: Yeah.
So, it's just the NFC question was a timer
issue between the different OS's of Android
with Gingerbread.
We were able to overwrite it.
But the way it launches in Ice Cream Sandwich
is it decides to time out it informs the application.
So the 0.3 seconds would not over allow the
certain types of card to be read and pass
through.
So I just want to do this--I'm stuck overplaying
this and you can't adjust this.
But I just wanted also to for forward warning
for future versions of Android whether we
can increase the default to one second?
>> BUTCHER: Yes.
And that sounds like a pretty specific question
which I'm not really familiar with.
Like have you gone to the [INDISTINCT] code
base and found where thatís [INDISTINCT]
>> HANSON: What you can do is on the ISO depth
you can call .settime outs and you can change
it to any value.
But the problem is the way that the NFC life
cycle is in Ice Cream Sandwich is it never
gets called because it doesnít launch the
app.
So I can't--when it says on tag it says in
the documentation that also since you close
the tag, it reverts back to its default time
out of 0.3 seconds.
But if you set it, you have to be in a code
to set it so you have to have launched the
application so thatís the problem.
The problem is Android won't launch the application
for those kind of cards.
The other cards will work, but the problem
is all of the new cards are going to be on
the 1.3 seconds so you can't change the cards.
>> BUTCHER: How are you treating into your
app?
You're doing it on in depth discover or you
doing on [INDISTINCT]
>> HANSON: Both.
>> HYNDMAN: And even on [INDISTINCT] it isn't
long enough [INDISTINCT]
>> HANSON: Basically I've got the code here.
Look, I'm doing [INDISTINCT] on action discovered
or on action tech discovered or on action
tag discovered, it goes--calls the same function.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
>> HANSON: Then I'll get the tag--I'll get
the tag object and then I immediately try
to call the set time out but in Ice Cream
Sandwich I can't even debug--I can't even
step into that code at all.
But on Gingerbread, you will get there.
Allow me to set the time out and then which
we allow the rest of the process to continue.
>> RHODE: Uh-hmm.
I wonder if thatís due to the lack of higher
level APIs like Android Beam.
>> HYNDMAN: I don't know but it's quite interesting
that Gingerbread lets you do that.
And the problem is theyíve been debugging
some of the phones and obviously you want
to try the Galaxy Note and the S3 and things
like that.
And I keep having to dig out in all characters
to try and get it to work.
>> RHODE: So, does it work if you pre-launch
the application?
>> HANSON: It doesnít appear to work if you
pre-launch or if it's launched from the tag
event.
I tried some tricks like making a static tag
object and try to hang on to the reference
to set the time out from a previous time but
I couldn't seem to get that to work either.
And it sounds a bit like a bad piece of engineering
as well.
>> RHODE: Yeah.
Well, there's a difference between just make
this work and go to production with it.
>> HANSON: Yeah.
>> RHODE: At least, I hope there's a difference.
>> HANSON: So, defining this--defining a short
translation I'd like to make it--I'd like
you to reconsider for the future, Android
version.
I could print out the default log.
>> BUTCHER: Well, the right way...
>> HANSON: Time out.
>> BUTCHER: ...the right way to voice that
feature is, would be to file a feature quest
on a AOSP.
>> SUTTON: Okay.
>> BUTCHER: So you go to dev.android.com,
which is both [INDISTINCT] bugs.
So there's a section there about fighting
bugs.
One of the types of bug, you can find in the
feature request.
>> HANSON: Okay.
>> BUTCHER: So, might as well report that
to us and you'll get logged and catalogued
and prioritized in that opinion and this day
on.
>> HANSON: Yes, because I think this problem
will affect the U.S. primary, the U.S. cards
will be like that as--and increasing in Europe,
so it will--it will kind of stop.
>> BUTCHER: Does this need static kind of
cards?
I've never heard of this.
>> HANSON: This is a cargo security on it.
So, it's basically, what happens is, when
the NFC event happens, it's pairing up, doing
a self check.
So, this--I think it's fragmented at the moment
but I think it's increasing.
This type of cards increasing nuisance it
was nowhere around.
We can't sort of change what cards people
are using, so over across the countries sort
of thing, so...
>> BUTCHER: It sounds interesting.
Could you...
>> HANSON: It's a current standard, sorry.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah [INDISTINCT] and send us
a link.
>> HANSON: Sorry?
>> BUTCHER: You write out this issue if you
posted just to step over for already.
>> HANSON: Yes.
So, I got it on stuff--stuck overflow.
There's a guy called NFC.
NFC guy is quite good.
And he knows this stuff because he works with
Android.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> HANSON: And his--had a few guys but, he
said--you said you can't do anything about
an Ice Cream Sandwich.
>> BUTCHER: And you think there's a link to...
>> HANSON: Yes, sort of, yeah, he went to
paste in this window here.
>> BUTCHER: No, because it will just go away
with in this Hangout.
He posted as a comment on the G+ event--of
the G+...
>> HANSON: Okay.
>> BUTCHER: This Hangout.
That'd be awesome.
>> HANSON: No problem.
>> RHODE: You can also post it in the chat.
I usually copy those and save them to a text
file at the end.
>> HANSON: All right.
I'll do both.
I have to look it up, but yeah, I mean, at
the very least, it would be good if the default
is at least one second.
We work with all kinds of cards because this
will be an issue in the U.S. as well.
But, yeah unless anyone short ideas.
I donít think it's that easy to sort it out,
to try a bit everything from stock overflows.
So, it's been--so, I've been looking out for
a few weeks.
>> SUTTON: I'm not sure if any on that you
dug into the Sourcescape.
There is a service which controls the time
out for reading tags and things like that.
>> HANSON: Okay.
>> SUTTON: If you can paste a link as Rich
and Nick asked for.
>> HANSON: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: I'll have to dig in to that and
see if there's a way to set it from a third
party application.
>> HANSON: That would be brilliant.
>> SUTTON: Because there seems to be methods
to set it but I'm not sure what restrictions
are placed on those methods whether they're
exposed to third party apps or not.
So, it may or may not work.
>> HANSON: Yes, because it's sort of put in
our custom [INDISTINCT] is only good for internal
but since we go out to other people, we won't
hesitate up but yeah, if the app can overwrite
something that would be fantastic to look
out...
>> SUTTON: Cool.
>> HANSON: Thank you very much.
>> All right.
>> HYNDMAN: You have a start to have to look
at the moderator this weekend?
>> RHODE: Well, we've got a couple of people
in the Hangout.
We've got, Sebastian, is that right?
And Richard Thompson.
Do you guys have anything you want to talk
about before we go into the moderator content?
>> BUTCHER: Richard is typing.
>> HYNDMAN: Yes, please.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: Matt's typing.
>> BUTCHER: What's that?
It's [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: While they're typing, maybe we can
get a moderator question.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT] all the way.
>> RHODE: Let's see how you guys are doing.
So, Crystal in Estonia wants to know.
He says, I have a web-based game that includes
purchase of digital goods.
Do I still have to use Google Wallet for purchases?
Sorry, yes.
We understand that Estonia is not a Google
Wallet emergent country.
But that still doesnít excuse you from the
terms of the Play Store, which is--if you're
hosted in Play Store you need to use Google
Wallet as your payment method mechanism.
There is the multi-platform work around but
we've discussed before where if you have a
piece of digital content that's an equally
useable in several different places like say
in, you know, the Amazon Music Player, the
Apple iTunes player or Google Music.
And the same digital purchase confers rates
to all these different platforms, then we
don't require you to use wallet, but otherwise,
basically our store, our payment method.
Sorry.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
We have commented on this before, there are
some applications that are great [INDISTINCT]
that are looked up by the [INDISTINCT] probably
abused it.
Which I'm glad is and their making a decision
on it.
Generally, you know, just stick to the guidelines.
Unfortunately, when it's not in your country,
then it's not possible to use, you cannot
pay all the paid app systems.
You could choose to partner with a publisher
in another country or do something else, which
enables you to have an account from another
country.
>> RHODE: Yeah, we got that we can't be everywhere
at once.
You know, we're working on it.
I also like to point out, we're not forcing
you to distribute your app through Google
Play.
You can choose another market if that's the
way you want monetize your app.
We have an open eco system and you're free
to do that.
>> HYNDMAN: No, I know.
I know that's the ideal answer, but the ideal
answer would be [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Okay.
So, we have a question aside from Richard
Thompson.
So, Richard and [INDISTINCT] Android design
guidelines, recommends a 16-depth margin on
the sides of your screen.
But he asks, what is the recommended padding
to the top and bottom as demonstrated by Rich.
Thank you for that.
[INDISTINCT] And so, I would probably say,
it depends on what you're showing, is commonly
the answer.
So, if you're showing like a list view for
example, I think that same screen on the--on
metrics [INDISTINCT] recommend, you know the
recommended like height, width 8 depths, above
and below.
So, you fall into the standard 48 depth ribbon.
So, that's, you know, one thing.
If you're not kind of going for context, straight
away, you might want to echo the 16-depth
margin, over the left and right to get an
even feel.
It kind of really depends on your content.
So, let's say...
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah personally I'd say if you
got an action bar at the top and the top is
well-defined.
You have to zero margin above that.
And the list is going to drill straight through
the bottom of the screen.
If you have any or whatever it is the content,
we'll be stretching to the bottom of the screen.
So, if you have any margins there, it might
be slightly confusing to the user, the UI's
ending.
Before...
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, because list item it cells
includes padding with in [INDISTINCT] on the
action bar, you wouldn't put a [INDISTINCT]
up against the action bar.
I probably go the 16-depths.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, [INDISTINCT] that.
You want it--must have it consistent.
>> BUTCHER: Well, if you're the designer on
it.
>> HYNDMAN: It seems, Sebastian jumped in.
>> RHODE: Great.
>> HYNDMAN: Richard says thank you.
And Sebastian says, I live in Venezuela and
we have had restrictions to use foreign currencies.
We have high restrictions.
Is there a possibility for us to sell our
apps in local currency in Play?
Would we go on and create a local market?
>> RHODE: We'll sort of just adjust that.
>> HYNDMAN: Sort of what, Sparky?
>> RHODE: We kind of just talked through that
one...
>> HYNDMAN: Well, Venezuela going to be a
merging country either, so can't sell your
apps in Google Play until we support Venezuela
as a merging country.
Unless that's not the case, if it is, then
the case [INDISTINCT] yes, you can create
a local market.
You potentially said it through the operator
stores if there are any.
Well, you can put it on Google Play and monetize
your different means.
Maybe, advertising, but the monetization option,
direct monetization of Google Play isn't open
to [INDISTINCT] countries.
>> SUTTON: I think one of the other problems
in Venezuela is actually lifted as a Play
Store, able to sell paid applications.
I donít know if he's having issues with the
fact of foreign exchange rules in Venezuela
or selling in things like U.S. dollars and
stuff like that may cause legal problems.
I think what we read around that is to developer
to just to select Venezuela is the only country
they sell to, as well.
>> HYNDMAN: Yes, Venezuela is listed as a
merging country and you have restrictions
on selling in foreign countries then, yeah.
Yes, they're also obeyed by your countries,
laws and regulations.
I donít know about tapping.
>> BUTCHER: We have another person joining
us whose name I cannot pronounce.
But he's got a [INDISTINCT] I looked it up.
>> HYNDMAN: Hey Nikola, yeah.
If you have any questions that would be a
good time to ask them.
In the meantime, thanks for posting those
links out and Paul.
Paul just posted a link to stock overflow
issue on Galaxy.
[INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Okay.
Do you have any more moderator questions?
>> HYNDMAN: We do.
Live in the room.
>> RHODE: I'm trying to get back to you guys.
I sort of lost your window.
>> HYNDMAN: You lost us.
>> BUTCHER: Sparky, come back.
>> RHODE: There you are--there you are.
This is the link to the emerging countries
of which I regret to say, Venezuela is not
one.
And for the record, neither is India.
>> HYNDMAN: Is the link that you posted are
the links of countries that you can sell out
as oppose the links you can sell them from?
>> SUTTON: [INDISTINCT] way you can sell it
from.
It's the Google Play for developers supported
locations for distributing applications.
>> HYNDMAN: That's where you can sell them
to, not sell them from.
>> SUTTON: What the last section says the
developers' needs locations may also sell
paid applications to use and the rest of the
world.
>> HYNDMAN: Look at the two links [INDISTINCT]
come take a look at the screen to that window
up there.
But I know there's only three different sections
in that document.
If it's one about 31 countries, then that's
the emerging [INDISTINCT].
If it's one of the 130 countries, then that's
the countries you can sell apps into and then
everything else is.
>> SUTTON: It looked--it looks like the 31
list, but if you have a look and to let us
know that'd be cool.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, sure.
Not that I--if I can get it work.
Do you want to run to the next question, Sparky.
>> RHODE: Sure.
We looked at that one.
Yohan Pilgrim in the Netherlands says, "Let's
say I add some stake to an activity being
an [INDISTINCT] and the activity is destroyed.
When to user navigates back to my activity
can I depend on the framework to reuse the
original attempt to start it?
I [INDISTINCT] the intent acts to be to there."
And it says, "To Labiridge, can I depend on
the original intent extra or do I need to
save it using on Stevens--on Stevens or something
like that.
Which of course would mean trying to retrieve
it from the extra etcetera."
So--and he can't be in the Hangout, so we're
free to talk about it without him.
We can say nasty things about him and he'll
never know until he watches the replay.
So my answer to him, at least the moderator
was it depends on how the activity was exited.
If it's--if it just got pushed down to the
stack by some other activities being open
on top of it, then I think the original intent
is still there.
But if the user presses the back button, then
the activity is destroyed and I think it's
going to take a whole new intent to get it
back again.
Does that sound right to you guys?
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
If you want things to be like saves and passed
in when it recreated, then use on savings
mistakes because that's what it's for.
>> SUTTON: And orientation change will also
kill off any extra swelter.
>> BUTCHER: Yup.
Tear it all down and create again.
Okay then.
I think our new joiner is--we got Jeff has
joined us.
AndÖ
>> HYNDMAN: Oh, it's just seven.
Oh, so it's Jeff [INDISTINCT], that would
be amazing.
>> BUTCHER: Oh, Jeff also is on in the sidebar
there.
Can we add the information about padding?
I don't know, because it's really a "it depends"
answer.
>> HYNDMAN: So the one that's fixed the side
padding would put that in the design guidelines
for the top and bottom.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: Does it meanÖ
>> BUTCHER: It would.
>> RHODE: It seems to me like we have kind
of sort of precedent of having a eighth-dps
design rule.
So you should, I mean, at the very least try
to separate things by eight-depths.
That kind of feels right to me.
It really takes me back to when we were designing
computer chips, you know, you get your minimum
feature size and everything's in multiples
of that.
I think our minimum feature size here is eight-dps.
>> BUTCHER: I think at least.
>> RHODE: I can't wait.
I just--I just can't wait for the future when
we start using VLSI design tools for running
software.
>> BUTCHER: Other tools are [INDISTINCT] if
not from a question.
>> Yeah.
I've got--I've got a question about the wallet,
just for our people talking, just talk.
Is there a provision for like storing tickets
on the wallet, or how does that thing work.
If you--if you want to sell to that party
ticket or something.
>> BUTCHER: Nope.
[INDISTINCT]
>> It's just purely payments, is it?
>> BUTCHER: As I understand that.
>> SUTTON: And a tiny pigments from a groove,
card approvers it's not sort of payments anyone
can add anything to.
>> Okay.
So if you-if you're making a payment, let's
say sell a ticket to an event, it's up to
you what you do with that ticket and how you
do it, if it's not tossed in the wallet in
any way.
>> BUTCHER: Right.
>> Okay.
There's no sort of encryption or authentication
or need in three persons purchase of that
stage tied to that.
So, okay.
So it's completely open.
>> BUTCHER: Yup.
>> Thank you.
>> BUTCHER: Any other questions for the room
or should we crack on with the moderator?
>> RHODE: I see that we've been joined by
Jetendra.
Does Jentendra have anything to ask?
No Android client for the Google+ video in
Hangout.
Yeah.
This is--it's, I mean, it's not a purely Hangout,
right.
It's this Google live, it's at--a YouTube
live stream.
I thought--I thought I heard from one of our
developers that he could see it.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, he can.
>> HYNDMAN: Oh, yes.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
He can see that.
That's probably--there's not likely [INDISTINCT]
inÖ
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
You should probablyÖ
>> BUTCHER: ÖGoogle passed for you.
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
I've had it running.
I had some issues with sounds but that's probably
my network bandwidth than anything else.
>> BUTCHER: Hey, is this YouTube, is this
live, right?
You just open YouTube and go to the live section
and we should be right there.
>> SUTTON: That's that.
And there's also you can join him with the
Hangouts on air from the Google+ client on
Android.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
Yeah.
It should work on Hangout on handsets.
>> BUTCHER: So, yeah.
Jeff says it works on his tablet, but not
on his HTC Evo 4G.
So I guess it's going to depend upon which
version of YouTube application you're running.
>> RHODE: Unsupportive data format.
>> BUTCHER: So I guessÖ
>> RHODE: SoÖ
>> BUTCHER: We've never seen that before.
Basically, YouTube spits out a live stream
in a variety of formats.
And it can take a little while before it spits
out the mobile friendly one, which is why
we're trying to start out the Hangout a little
bit before--we're actually going to start
broadcasting.
And then you turn on live.
So it might just be a case of checking back
a little bit later.
Sorry about that.
Sometimes it's how YouTube works.
>> RHODE: So you think it's just--it's just
a processing pipeline delay then?
That's interesting.
>> BUTCHER: That's one of the potential issues
that you can give that and answer.
The other thing I was thinking could be, if
you had an older version [INDISTINCT] for
some reason.
And you--that might not support the Hangout
[INDISTINCT].
So check regularly what the latest version.
>> HYNDMAN: Generally, if you guys follow
the YouTube, comment to Jeff live, we'll chat
with him afterwards.
We usually follow the comment on the Google+
posting for this like event and also on the
moderator.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: And the YouTube comments aren't
quite the same quality.
>> BUTCHER: Yes.
Any places people's post comments in YouTube
Live since to be the lowest [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: You know, I could--I could see having
somebody follow the YouTube comment if we
were able to devote, you know, to devote a
person who monitor the streams as oppose to
having everybody on camera all the time.
I don't know if our viewers are aware of this,
but when you look at the Hangouts that are
run by the California team, they've got so
many guys over there that they always got
one or two people off camera producing the
show.
What you get hear in EMEA is the entire Android
Developer Organization on camera talking to
you live.
Hello.
>> BUTCHER: Definitely, it's a good point
there like I had say how as the ask questions,
dude?
I'd say jump up the stream screen and go into
the G+ client or something.
But it's usually the third point.
So maybe we should start wondering in somehow.
>> HYNDMAN: So far, there any one question
in the YouTube screen, and it's fromÖ
>> BUTCHER: Jeff.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, Jeff.
Good to hear that.
>> BUTCHER: Hey to all.
>> Hello.
Sorry for the late join and forgot which time
zones here.
We are all living Winter times.
>> HYNDMAN: Ah, you were [INDISTINCT] pretty
switched.
We can't be far of switching.
Well, not by here.
Screws up all the calendars.
Okay.
Moderator.
>> RHODE: You know, I'm just looking at that
moderator.
Remember a couple of questions keep trickling
in while we are talking.
And that's [INDISTINCT] let me scroll down
to the right one.
"Any idea if it's possible to change the animation
of a ViewPager to something other than a slide?
I.E.
And after our style overlapping transition."
All right then.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I mean, ViewPager is at the source.
If you've downloaded the [INDISTINCT] it's--the
source is even lying on your computer right
now, on the Android SDK extras compatibility
Google something.
You'll see it down there, support source.
And you can put those words in any order,
and it will just be there.
Manager's magic.
I've read through the source myself and played
around with it.
Yeah, you canÖ
>> BUTCHER: It's incredibly real, right?
>> HYNDMAN: It is.
>> BUTCHER: I think I highly recommend that
one to take a look at the source of ViewPager
because it's very, very readable, very well-structured.
And you can learn a lot.
Let's say good job Adam Hall.
>> HYNDMAN: Good job Adam Hall, yeah.
So you can look into that and play around
with it, change the way it works.
Change animations if you really want to.
It's already got the thing that tracking built
in, just quite nice.
So, yes, you can.
>> BUTCHER: Yes.
So I'd say you'd probably want to extend the
ViewPager and change it rather than--
I don't think there's a setting to change
animation on the ViewPagerÖ
>> HYNDMAN: No.
>> BUTCHER: Öfor you, looking and creating
your own widget.
But, yeah, I'd say like 95% of the web has
done it for you already, if you start from
the ViewPager.
>> HYNDMAN: You can call it draw slider pager
or something.
[INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Or if you want it to look the
apps tray, why don't you look at the source
code of the apps tray.
>> HYNDMAN: It's true.
>> BUTCHER: Which is in Launcher2 [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: Excellent.
Where's the [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
[INDISTINCT] Launcher2.
This is [INDISTINCT] I forget.
>> HYNDMAN: Thank you, unknown for the question.
One of our more, more popular contributors.
>> SUTTON: It is still Launcher2.
>> HYNDMAN: Jeez.
Well, I was looking back at that link as well,
Al.
And that is listed countries that you can
sell apps in to.
A bit where it says, developers in these countries
may also sell to other countries.
That in these countries is a link when you
click on that, you see that there's a countries.
>> SUTTON: All right.
So that's not that at least it's below that
sentence.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
And then you get to the--doesn't have Valenzuela
in it.
>> SUTTON: No.
>> HYNDMAN: It's good.
>> SUTTON: Thanks for checking out, Rich.
>> HYNDMAN: Plus the hundred and thirty [INDISTINCT]
I'm looking in to implementing the Android
Backup Service in my app.
It saysÖ
>> BUTCHER: Yehey.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, right.
Well, people should look into doing that.
>> BUTCHER: I love that service.
>> HYNDMAN: But I can't find any examples
on how to use SQLite database.
>> Any ideas?
>> HYNDMAN: Is there a sequel helper for the
backup service?
>> RHODE: I kind of thought the point to the
backup service was for restoring devices.
>> BUTCHER: [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: Just a little.
>> RHODE: Wouldn't you want to do it off device?
>> HYNDMAN: So the other backup service, yes.
I think what he wants to is just want to backup
to a SQLite database, a backup SQLite databaseto
the Cloud.
Well, he wantsÖ
>> BUTCHER: Oh, right.
I interpret it as the backup and restore service.
Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT]
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, the thing when it restores
your shared preferences and whatnot when you
had logged into a new device.
I'm not going toÖ
>> HYNDMAN: It says I can't find examples
on how to use with SQLite database.
And that is--it's a--there is a confusion
now.
He may be talking about using the backup service
to back up to a database.
We use to backup service to backup SQLite
databaseto the Cloud.
Because that is possible.
>> BUTCHER: I think he means the Cloud service
not the--it could beÖ
>> HYNDMAN: Now that the examples we have
are filed back up and share preferences [INDISTINCT].
It's the fun.
I mean, really, he wants us to backup sort
of [INDISTINCT] that would be silly.
Yeah, I think, talking about SQLite databasefor
the Cloud?
>> SUTTON: Isn't part of the thing--the issue
that when you synchronize a back up, you got
no guarantee it's going to just sequel database.
So there's no ability to translate or sequel
database on the device directly to a sequel
database in the Cloud because you don't know
that's where to be stored.
So it'sÖ
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: Ögoing to need to write some kind
of translator that puts in the different format
anyway.
>> HYNDMAN: SoÖ
>> SUTTON: I mean doing a generic model is
going to be difficult because you need to
make assumptions about the database.
>> HYNDMAN: You can blob it, but if you just
want to sample and write the database on restore
which is fine to sequel with the database
is, you can just back up the blob at SQLite
database.
And then when you restore, just see if it's
going to, just check time grab the latest
format.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT].
Yeah, a nice way of doing it would be to synchronize
the database, but then you've got to--yeah,
do exactly that.
Figure out what date has changed, when it
changed and do the synchronizations more like
Gmail does it.
When you hit the refresh you see something
else, too many things appearing.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: Some [INDISTINCT] everyone else.
>> SUTTON: I think there's muting war going
on.
>> HYNDMAN: I'm just going to look for an
example code for it.
>> BUTCHER: I don't know that if it wonít
runÖ
>> HYNDMAN: Or maybe we should have one.
Yeah, slightly tricky.
>> BUTCHER: I'm mostly curious about what
back data you're trying to back up if it's
like large SQL database.
I'm not sure that's exactly what it's intended
for.
Nothing is more so like backing up configurations
and settings and so on and so forth.
Such that you if you accidentally step on
your device and smash you screen then get
a new one.
And when you locate and everything is the
same as you left it.
>> SUTTON: There's a stack-overflow question
which shows a very quick way of backing up
a whole SQLite databases as a blowup or stick
a link to in the comments or just paste.
>> HYNDMAN: That's definitely going to be
easier that's why anything else, I mean like
almost--just look at the--that preferences
back up.
How close was that it gives you an idea if
what you--if you want to do the synchronization
as well of each individual database item.
>> RHODE: Okay.
We'll see we've got a couple new people in
Hangout.
We got the Armeda Streind and Jodith Streind.
So welcome to Hangout guys.
If you have anything that you want to discuss
regarding Android Application Development,
you just let us know.
So they don't know how to skip to particular
point in the YouTube video mobile.
Oh, I understand you can embed that in URL.
I don't know if you can do it.
>> BUTCHER: I think theÖ
>> HYNDMAN: It would be otherwiseÖ
>> BUTCHER: Öpoint is read between the lines
is anything which broke us on YouTube Live
infrastructure doesnít let you use the scrubber,
that little progress bar to skip ahead and
specially if you're actually watching a live
broadcast.
You can't do that.
>> HYNDMAN: I want the future.
Damn it.
>> BUTCHER: Maybe you can skip back.
It's like early [INDISTINCT} structure.
>> HYNDMAN: No, you can't downstream.
There's a limitation to the YouTube Live mobile
just to stream into it.
>> BUTCHER: I think--well, I think after a
period of time, once YouTube processes it
then it comes a regular video.
That the recording after this will become
a regular YouTube video at some point you'll
be able to scrub back and forth and not the
first answer.
>> HYNDMAN: Yes.
It's definitely awhile after because I've
checked.
It's been an hour or two after.
It still just has the play through the entire
live show as an option.
>> BUTCHER: Uh-hmm.
>> HYNDMAN: But if you go to the web version,
then you can scrub back and forth.
I was trying to continue to watch some broadcast
on my file but couldn't skip to where I got
to on my pc.
Yeah, that's a current limitation of the watching
a YouTube Live video on the YouTube mobile
phone.
You have to go back to the--you may be able
to get away with it if you got Flash installed.
You might go to the web browser and go through
that and not let YouTube launch it.
Maybe I'd have to go forward to the right
point of the video, through the browser.
>> BUTCHER: You Flash it.
>> RHODE: You can add that.
I mean certainly it comes in where you can--where
you can bookmark something on your pc and
have it show up on your Mac or Google Maps
where you can star something and want to have
it show on the other.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> RHODE: You need to have that with YouTube
too.
Just you know, push my video from my phone
straight to my desktop and keep watching.
>> HYNDMAN: That works very well with theÖ
>> BUTCHER: That works with phone to tablets
between, right?
[INDISTINCT]
>> HYNDMAN: And on the Nexus Q, you can just
bring your tablet, TV tablet up and down and
that's [INDISTINCT].
>> RHODE: And Ahmad has reposted this question.
It doesnít say it wanted the [INDISTINCT]
rate it average.
> HYNDMAN: Well, Google App Engine will be
a good option instead of Amazon Web Services.
Good question.
Yes.
Oh, okay, there's more.
For writing, reading data with low latency
when we have thousands of users performing
read/write to server.
The issue is was when data is shredded and
the response time needs to be very small.
Would Google App Engine handle something like
Instagram?
Do we have any used cases similar to it.
We've got Memcache.
>> RHODE: Right, so your default method of
saving things and apprehension is data store
which of course is, you know, shared by all
the different front ends that are accessed,
you know, all the different front end instances
that are serving your app.
And then you got Memcache which keeps things
in memory.
It's, you know, like it sounds.
It's small fast, low latency.
So I would say yes.
>> HYNDMAN: Oh, there you go.
I recommend that you go to the office hours
of the Apps team.
>> BUTCHER: Cloud Team.
>> HYNDMAN: You can go to, yeah, go to developers.google.com/live.
The Cloud team have office hours.
This is the Android office hours.
So we're not going to read any answers to
question on there on their product, but you
can go to their office hours and ask them
about it.
And they'll give you some really detailed
answers on exactly that used case.
>> BUTCHER: They'll tell you yes.
>> HYNDMAN: They'll say yes, but they'll also
take it.
I hope.
So, yeah, I meant, have a littleÖ
>> BUTCHER: Have a little a reason why.
>> HYNDMAN: Developers.google.com/live [INDISTINCT]
houses, big tables do you think?
We put a lot of things in a big table.
We have 600 on the thread.
>> BUTCHER: Oh, yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: They're from Al.
This is for the [INDISTINCT].
Why from the Google+ [INDISTINCT] to the Hangout.
Okay.
They're also being reposted and [INDISTINCT].
Back to the moderator.
>> RHODE: Yeah, it's one in the moderator.
This is a little bit forward looking.
It says, when are you guys going to straighten
out HTML5 video for Android?
Video opens do not---it was documented methods
do not respond as documented.
Could you make this priority?
I can't.
I'm sure the browser team can.
My question--my follow up questions to him
were, what version of Android are you on and
are you seeing it for example in the full
browser or in the web view?
I would say generally speaking, you'll probably
see the correct functionality in the browser
first and if it's not correct now, by all
means please let us know because the full
browser should be about as good as Chrome.
>> HYNDMAN: With the Nexus 7 and only can
shift with the Chrome browser.
So Android web browser development ongoing
is from the Chrome team.
I imagine that it's what--confined with Chrome
and Android, but if it's not, then I'm sure
that's it's very important to them to ensure
that it is--Chrome is updated outside of the
Android cycles.
So you can get an update for it at any point.
>> BUTCHER: And Firefox.
>> HYNDMAN: And Firefox.
Feedback actually that's very good point.
If you are using the latest version of Chrome
for Android and you're seeing this issue.
Please do find a bug.
If you're using a previous version of Android
down unfortunately, you have to wait for a
few more firmware update until because for
Ice Cream Sandwich and then you can install
Chrome.
Okay.
>> RHODE: Yeah, in terms of--in terms of development
priorities going forward definitely at Chrome
on Android is where the activity is and the
pre-Chrome Android browser although also web
good browser is not going to get as much attention.
>> SUTTON: I've heard the Chrome is shipping
one of the new Motorola devices as part of
the Google Apps Week.
SoÖ
>> HYNDMAN: Where on Earth did hear that?
[INDISTINCT] in the Motorola [INDISTINCT]
the other day.
>> SUTTON: Yeah, the--that seems quite interesting
thing to see happened.
Does that mean that future devices are going
to have it or it's a future statement.
I know you guys can't comment, butÖ
>> HYNDMAN: No, that's an interesting thing.
I don't know when other manufacturers launch,
try making new devices.
Would that be replacing the any present model.
>> RHODE: Okay.
>> Well, the annoying thing the Galaxy Nexus
they didn't kill the [INDISTINCT] browser
same thing in Jelly Bean.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, Nexus 7 was the first device
to be Chrome memory.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, that's because it was upgrade
for Nexus, not a--yeah, Galaxy--sorry, Nexus
7, you know the first time out the box.
We could do that, but we don't want to remove
an app from a user's phone because they just
stole an upgrade that would be a pretty bad
experience.
>> HYNDMAN: [INDISTINCT] delete bookmarks
and everything.
>> Well, but they can add the Google Chrome,
not to remove the browser, but to add the
new browser.
>> HYNDMAN: That's what they did, yeah.
>> They had?
>> SUTTON: If Chrome for Android is still
in beta or is it moved to a production release?
>> HYNDMAN: Let me see.
The new--that was about [INDISTINCT] the web,
okay, [INDISTINCT]
>> All right.
>> HYNDMAN: It says Chrome for mobile, it
doesnít say.
>> It's very good.
>> HYNDMAN: Oh, got you.
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: No, there's nothing.
It's just this [INDISTINCT]
>> RHODE: Cool.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
Yes.
It's very good.
Next question.
Did you read that question?
>> BUTCHER: Yes, I did.
>> RHODE: Next question, the moderator, yes,
date picker dialog displays correctly in ICS
if Android themes set the Android Theme.Light,
but if it set to Android style/theme.NoTitleBar,
date picker dialog displays as if in a previous
Android versions.
I'm using DialogFragment and Support Live.
>> BUTCHER: That sounds....
>> RHODE: There's not really a question there.
>> BUTCHER: That sounds like it's working
as intended to me.
It appears Theme.Light if you're running on
ICS, [INDISTINCT] styling, if you want to
see the styling where is the theme.
>> HYNDMAN: NoTitleBar.
>> BUTCHER: NoTitleBar, that's a pre-colored
style.
>> HYNDMAN: I wouldÖ
>> BUTCHER: So I would expect it to look pre-colored.
>> HYNDMAN: I'd say you need to go into yeah,
Theme.Holo.Light.NoTitleBar to get what you're
looking for.
>>RHODE: Now, if I remember correctly and
I--I'm sure you guys know if you set a theme
with no title bar, then you lose your hollow
action bar, is that right?
>> BUTCHER: I think so, yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
>> RHODE: So don't do that.
>> HYNDMAN: Well maybe you want a full screen
gallery or something.
>> BUTCHER: It's still dialogue though, right?
>> HYNDMAN: Or a dialogue, yeah.
>> RHODE: It's fine.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, but look for Theme.Holo.Light.NoTitleBar.
I believe it's there, I'm pretty sure.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, it's just be explicit about
wanting the hollow styling, if you would just
implicitly getting it by toggling theme.live
before.
But the explicit value, and you all get the
expected result.
>> RHODE: I don't know if it's just that I'm
a huge fan of hollow or if I'm lazy, but I
never set styles on my applications.
I mean, I let them system default all the
time.
>> SUTTON: There's an interesting app in one
of the app review sessions that actually had
an auction in the overflow menu that allowed
you to change between hollow light and hollow
dark.
That seems to be quite interesting.
>> BUTCHER: Which the--oh, that was the--one
of the [INDISTINCT] ones that's recently looked
at.
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
I mean, what are you guys feelings on that?
Do you like to see it, would you not like
to see it?
>> BUTCHER: Personally...
>> HYNDMAN: I'd like to be book readers.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah, I think there's such cases
where it's useful but I don't generally like
too many settings.
The whole, just make it a setting thing is
a bit, you know, it's like techy, developer
got type people.
We live it, like we love, you know, to tweet
a little notes and change everything.
But if you ever watch real users use your
app and look at world on their face when they
see too many options then, I think it's a
good thing to minimize choice to go in sensible
default.
>> HYNDMAN: Sometimes it makes sense for widgets
as well because you don't know what kind of
cover background or wallpaper the users are
going to have.
So it's quite nice to theme for widget.
I often use the transparent ones or the darker
ones.
Sometimes I switch it when I have a lighter
background, because it looks nicer.
So be aware of, yeah, the context the application
is going to be shown in.
>> BUTCHER: Or another thing might be, if
you do have a settings page, consider breaking
out your settings in different--with common
core settings and the more advance section.
Something like that so they're not completely
overwhelming for more casual users.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Personally, for no settings quite possible.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, you should make the right
choices on their behalf.
>> RHODE: I'm sort of--I've been a believer
for a number of years that offering an excess
of configurations and settings basically is
just abdicating a responsibility as a designer.
And that the difference between a really good
system or app and a not so good one is when--is
when the designers really think things all
the way through and make the best decision
for most of the people.
You know, it's just like you said, and excessively
flexible system is a chaotic one and just
leaves people looking bewildered.
And you can look to, for example the major
competing desktop platforms and see which
one made the really, really detailed design
decisions and thought things all the way through
to the end and which ones just said, oh, let's
just make everything an option.
We can support 17 different ways to shut down
the system because there's different users
for each one.
And instead, it kind of makes nobody happy.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, and Android provides a lot
of facilities for taking that responsibility
away from the user.
If you're going to be storing data in your
application, like the [INDISTINCT] decision,
whether you're storing it as cache or data,
locally or data on the SD card and let system
manage that cache.
You need to scrub it if it needs to scrub
it maybe it'll disappear.
But something like Google+ I've just checked
on my tablet is using 200 Megs in the cache
but only about five megs of its SD card data
outside of that.
So if the--if it needs to be recovered, it
can and the app would still work properly.
But what you don't want is a little slider
in the app saying how much data you want to
use as a setting.
Just position the data correctly so the system
can deal with it.
>> BUTCHER: Okay.
Are we out of questions?
Anybody, come hit us.
>> HYNDMAN: Didn't some say they were going
to stomp us with questions.
>> Well it's not stated development questions,
it's more like from handling system itself.
I went a bit--wanted to see the new version,
you know, the Galaxy started getting Jellybean.
>> HYNDMAN: Yup.
>> And doing the update for the Samsung "KS"
the computer shut it down by the update.
And now the device is not really one thing
to tell on any ideas though I can get a--how
I get it backed up and running.
>> BUTCHER: Oh no.
>> HYNDMAN: So you were flashing your device
through Samsung keys and the computer shutdown
during the flash?
>> Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: How?
>> BUTCHER: And it gets a bit later?
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, can you do--probably down
in power or anything.
>> Well, I can get to download more data recovery
and to the [INDISTINCT] and others, so yeah.
I can get to one of the...
>> HYNDMAN: Can you connect it to fastboot?
>> BUTCHER: So that would be sufficient for
communications and device.
You can get to the boot later.
So you should be able to just re-flash it
again, right?
>> No, because it came from the case, so I
don't have the actual one.
>> BUTCHER: No, but you can connect to the
keys in case you'll can be able to see it.
>> I tried, the keys doesn't recognize the
phone.
>> BUTCHER: Oh, dear.
>> Yeah.
>> HYNDMAN: Is that when it's in fastboot
or is it when it's on boot loader?
>> It's--when I turn it on, you know, it tries
to find the device.
It only say loading thing but doesn't actually
find it.
And in boot loader I see it, but the key doesn't
You know, it do the, finds the other devices
and it sees it but not the...
>> HYNDMAN: In fastboot, you can reboot it
in the boot loader right?
>> Yes, on fastboot I can get to the boot
loader, but I need the actually one in order
to flash it.
>> HYNDMAN: So keys doesn't see it from fastboot
or boot loader?
>> No.
>> HYNDMAN: And you've tried doing a factory
reset, erase data, all that kind of thing?
>> I can't because it doesn't boot up to the--it
doesn't have an OS because it crashed on halfway
writing the new updates so there's nothing
to erase.
>> HYNDMAN: Have you been on fastboot?
>> Yeah.
Well I think, you know, the best thing I found--I
thought is to flash it, you know, to go to
Sam mobiles and download the ROM and then
try to flash it and then hope for the best.
>> HYNDMAN: Managing ROM for it?
>> Well I can try Sam engine mobile, so yeah.
That might work.
>> RHODE: I've heard of that before.
I mean I've heard of people using--is it clockwork,
is that the boot loader that...
>> SUTTON: Clockwork and tablet.
>> RHODE: Non-samsung devices.
>> SUTTON: If you can get it into odin mode,
keys should report it.
If you have a chat with Samsung support they
should talk you through that because odin
makes their equipment to fastboot and it's
what keys talks to it using.
>> Okay.
So I need to practice [INDISTINCT] in a little
bit.
>> SUTTON: Either that or Google translate
and post in the forums.
>> Okay.
Thank you.
>> HYNDMAN: It's a shame though.
>> It's going to be a fun date.
>> SUTTON: Yeah.
>> Well but it happens sometimes.
>> HYNDMAN: No, I probably flash thirty-five
or six times a day.
>> SUTTON: I always flash from the laptop.
>> When?
>> SUTTON: Plugged into the power with a full
battery charged.
I know it's one of those things that everybody
says.
Nobody really takes any notice, but I've seen
too many devices break to take the risk.
>> Well, you know, the advantage over the
Nexus devices when you flash stop, it's much
easier to do it than any other devices.
>> BUTCHER: Yes, of course.
>> SUTTON: And ther are also factory images
quite widely available for the Galaxy Nexus
and next devices from Google.
>> BUTCHER: Nexus.
>> Yes.
There's a lot of--it's very easy.
It's basically one--it's like two commands
I think that flash and then off you go.
I've got the [INDISTINCT] 10 on the Galaxy
Nexus and it's quite amazing what they did.
>> HYNDMAN: Good, what you mean?
Have you got any examples?
>> You know, the--again as I said, it's more
like for the geek stuff so there's a lot more
settings and...
>> SUTTON: Relax.
I could see Sparky sort of twinging at the
word more settings.
>> Yeah.
I lot more settings.
But the advantage is it recognizes a lot more
APNs, you know, for mobile data and stuff
like that.
So new mobile companies that started here
in Israel about two months ago and that have
been updated to the Android--to the Android
official OS.
And also, you know, the--well it's not an
issue anymore but the Hebrew stuff also is
there so it's also an advantage.
>> SUTTON: It also has an interesting SMS
reply thing using rich notifications, doesn't
it?
>> Yes, it does.
It shows you and then you can press it.
>> SUTTON: So you're rich notification tells
you about an SMS and you can use one of the
buttons to get a dialog box and reply to that
SMS straight away without going into the SMS
app.
>> Yes.
And also it can actually see since the rich
notification--notifications, you can see the
message itself which is quite nice.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
>> And the Google now also which is very nice
thing to have.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
>> BUTCHER: All right.
So if there's no more Android def questions,
maybe we'll wrap up five minutes early and
give your five minutes back in your day.
>> SUTTON: Kind of odd, I've seen announced
by Sony, a competition for the UK to develop
games for the 25,000 pound prize.
>> BUTCHER: Oh.
>> SUTTON: So it's, apparently deadline for
submission is the end of October.
I'll post the link in the--in the comments
for the--this hangout and maybe some people
will be able to write some cool games and
let's see what they come up with.
>> HYNDMAN: Richard Thomson just quickly asked
if he's still in, whether if anyone know about
updates for the IO edition galaxy tabs.
The IO edition Galaxy tabs did get onto the
main update stream at some point and I believe
Samsung just haven't announced when they're
going to roll out the 3g updates yet.
They're only doing the Wi-Fis so when they
do the updates for the 3g variants as well
and it's about the...
>> BUTCHER: Galaxy tab Wi-fi?
>> RHODE: They had announced updates for Galaxy
Tab 2, right?
Is that right?
>> Yeah, the Galaxy Tab 1 doesn't get Jellybean.
They said it's...
>> HYNDMAN: No, they already started rolling
the Galaxy Tab 1 Jellybean update up.
Oh, Ice Cream Sandwich, sorry, update.
We're still talking about the Ice Cream Sandwich.
>> BUTCHER: yeah, they got [INDISTINCT] Jellybean
Update.
>> HYNDMAN: Galaxy Tab 2 got Jellybean Update.
Because they had one, they announced the ICS
update for the Wi-Fi variant.
And none of my Galaxy Tabs have been updated
yet.
But, hopefully they'll announce one for the
rest of the variants at some point.
>> What about the--I'm getting better at sending
the updates.
If you look, for example on Jellybean, it's
been out for what, about two months, something
like that.
And then they already have it on the Galaxy
S3, they're starting to have it on the Galaxy
S3.
>> BUTCHER: Okay.
I'm really, really pleased to see that.
>> HYNDMAN: The migration from Ice Cream Sandwich
to Jellybean I think is much easier for the
companies as well then it was from.
>> BUTCHER: And so in terms of applying Jellybean
Update, started shipping.
>> SUTTON: And there is also the announcement
of IO about the PDK, the Platform Development
Kit which is shipping to big OEM's ahead of
an actual release so that they get a chance
to run up to speed before it hits--before
release gets out to the public.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah.
>> SUTTON: Just called to say.
>> HYNDMAN: Yes.
That would help the problem.
>> BUTCHER: Yeah.
Anything we can do to help those update cycles
[INDISTINCT] you know, that's great news.
>> HYNDMAN: Okay.
>> I remember between Gingerbread and ICS,
it was a very big time span between when Google
actually released it and when the devices
actually got it.
>> HYNDMAN: Yeah, this was a massive update.
The final incriminate release dates.
All right everyone, thank you very much for
tuning in.
Same time next week, hopefully from our studio.
>> BUTCHER: Bye guys.
>> SUTTON Thanks guys.
>> RHODE: All right.